[Music]
[Music]
giggles my baby
[Music]
you
I used to call you my girl
[Music]
loving everything you do - you bet sue
we know that I'll be checking you out
when you be putting years Oh sweetie
pies so perfect baby how you work your
baby yeah
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
this feeling
see long as it's a to get you all but as
soon as you come walking away you're
gonna hear me say there goes my baby
I call you my girl
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
there goes
[Music]
to call you my girl goes come
[Music]
love in everything you do
and it feels like a first start every
time we get together
[Music]
[Music]
and I promise it's all the way won't
change my
[Music]
feels that call you my girl
[Music]
you
[Music]
Oh what is going on you do now I know
this is not the normal upload date and I
guess you guys are wondering why I put
up a song instead of a comedy video well
before I started doing comedy I actually
started doing music way before that and
it was just a dream that kind of died
out and you guys have probably seen this
video before but I wanted to put it on
my channel for those of you that don't
know that actually did music so why am I
putting this out us is because soon I am
going to be releasing more and more
covers and also some originals yes yes I
hope you guys enjoyed that video I got
some other stuff that I'll be putting up
real soon but uh yeah I'm sharing this
one of my life with you music hope y'all
like it and if you hated it and [ __ ]
gimme binocular tell me what's a man
supposed to do because I'm stronger
smarter more conscious of your needs
you ain't got every bad a thing cuz when
you need me hold me I'll give you what
you need listen to my heart won't you
play your ball at need
[Music]